who is it
i'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
it's day three i'm heading to germany
overnight
uh for a keynote on saturday in cologne
we're in the trenches now we've got our
system settled
card put you know car talks going on
right here dustin
show
uh
and uh we're locked in now establishing
the friends
spending times with my favorite people
supporting and loving my favorite people
and going through it like
best we can
[Music]
come by the table i might buy some
friends please do come by
might be the [ __ ] i'm on forever baby
would you still wanna hold me down
she said i see you be right wanna see
you be happy what if
it's unbelievable how bad the location
is
yeah it looks amazing over there it's
not even that just like how people are
walking through the other aisles the
show's packed over there look at this
look look at it
yeah like just like against the wall is
death no shot
we just got too much to do just wait
we're sitting proper today
[Music]
let's go let's go close it up for now um
let's bring those over we'll close that
case just want to get a sense underneath
the tables see if there's anything that
we're missing
any boxes of any cards or anything like
that got it yeah so look through and
anything that's open boxes just stack to
make it more visual than just cardboard
over there yes james yes
this is helping me so much
you're like a bird cleaning cleaning
you guys help i just want to
get this look more organized we got
deals over here
hold up
when i look up in the
[Music]
mirror this year okay
it's been good how about for you all
right no no one's really dying
i know it feels like there's not a lot
of liquid right it feels like everyone's
looking to trade
one day people are gonna be really sad
that they didn't buy these we got
unlimited plans i'm going to make a good
impact and like the stories are real and
it goes kind of like not just goofy
poopy like one of my favorite characters
is a countable ant
and it's like yo you need to be [ __ ]
accountable
like stop blaming your [ __ ] parents
you know so it's a lot of that it's it's
me
in 300 character form i'm gonna build my
marvel and my [ __ ] pokemon
and i'm gonna watch the videos of this
national where everybody did buy these
for 60 and 30 and 200 bucks i want their
[ __ ] pokemon in 15 years i'm going to
get a real [ __ ] kick out of it
where do you think the browns are going
next year
that's the wildest one of them all yeah
because you don't know how long deshawn
suspended the impact yeah i hope i win
17. yeah because i hate every afc team
i hate every afc team but the jets yeah
i hate the browns
what are the jets record next year seven
and ten gary says seven and ten let me
know what you guys think thank you thank
you
you don't say go bill's to a crazy chess
fan he might want to fight
you sign a brave bison i got one of
these but i'll buy this one here 100
another bills fan bought the other one i
didn't realize i still had one
all right thanks for having me
always have to do it have a good season
buddy
both jackson cards are not going up
but like john moran cards could if he
wins four titles
so
99 of nfts are going to zero
but if kyle executes then his won't
so it's all execution is just the first
one you've opened yeah wow
that's first time's good luck
especially with the man yeah i hope so
ty
what we got yeah this is the box
in here right
actually what do we want here
so clip it so like flip it like this yep
here we go
another rare go ahead
yeah i know your orange is next out of
five
this box is nuts characterized
it's either a diamond or an auto it's an
auto or a diamond i think it's diamond
first i wanna i don't know
what there's two one on one
no the next one might be i think the
next one's auto which is huge go down
slow because on the top right it'll say
autographs
it's either hollow raw
i think it's signed go down slow yeah
you can save it
three
three that's two he crushes this guy
crush this box yeah crush sleeve
great job going that's [ __ ] monster
box brother now i'm just visiting
airplane private
[ __ ] under my wings
gary what's the vibes at
uh i have no idea i've been stuck behind
this table taking selfies 800 hours a
day
no clue literally no [ __ ] clue how's
your natural going so far tremendous i
love taking selfies with people what's
the what's the headline monday morning
post national of the of the hobby state
of the hobby right now cards everything
in general people aren't really spending
cash a lot of people trying to trade um
baseball's dead as [ __ ]
um ohtani is like dominating the sport
nobody gives a [ __ ]
um
so that's kind of a couple things i've
heard anything cooking with b friends in
the next few months at all or
yeah we have a substantial amount
announcement about the utility uh aspect
of the project we gave a little bit of a
preview with mint mink uh so that's
going on it's been really fun to cross
into the cards world with be friends uh
i'm looking to make sure that in 15
years
everybody looks back at this interview
and looks back at the prices that these
suckers were you make sure you capture
this video but the prices are i'm gonna
poke him on the [ __ ] out of everybody
and they're gonna be sad as [ __ ] so
that's my agenda all right there you
have it have a great show thank you
[Music]
if you could give your advice to
yourself when you're 21 yes what's the
one
i lived it i i realized then
that all of my friends and everybody in
the world under 30
is just so [ __ ] impatient because
they worry about other people's opinions
and so
i was just focused on doing what i
wanted to do
and at that time in my life
it was to help my parents business
and so i would just
i told myself that i'm gonna have
unlimited time to achieve every goal i
that's what i'm in the have of doing
well-rounded is what i teach him to be
you know
everything you know
and then pick two or three things to go
deep on you're [ __ ] set that's why i
like curiosity too curiosity leads you
to well-roundedness i've been doing the
cards i've done this for two years like
what's best advice care about customers
care about customers
care about customers
are you doing pack battles today
probably around five we're gonna play
the friends game we're gonna play the v
friends game all right i like it should
i explain to everyone what the v friends
game is or will they pick it up as we're
playing the it's war all these cards
have numbers on them yep and we're just
gonna go one two three flip
and
that is how it's played
there's variations in tournaments coming
yeah yep but the first game is just
head-to-head war where you can watch
tournaments
all over the world all over the world
all right all right i'll show up to one
thank you you're pretty good yeah yeah
one two three flip
me
you got that one i want 57.55 60.
61. let's [ __ ] go all right one two
three flip
guys i'm one of the great players
guys i'm on fire wow all right here we
go
oh my god
and so when you get a parallel yeah the
score bounces up
right now i see that okay i like the
hollow on it's nice
i cannot believe i haven't lost i mean
we we've been playing all week nobody's
ever won the spinning around this is
ridiculous you got to give me one man
i've never seen somebody win this fight
i don't take a pair you you owe me
something if i get zero by one he had
four by one on me
four or five just
oh my god what
is the odds are absurd
this is [ __ ] crazy what do i get if
you win the next four you might shoot
the moon and win the whole game
all right all right guys
the wine glass wine glass b2b nope i get
you drunk i get you drunk i take the no
if i tell them what do i get i need
somebody if you're watching this
i need somebody to give me the math
around what's happening right now in the
comments please
one two three shoot
how am i going to come back there's no
way to
thank you yeah thank you thank you so
much keep up with the great work hey i
appreciate it i appreciate it that was
fun yeah that was fun
[Music]
thank you for the best time you guys
fighting you got three friends yet
all right let's hook it up here we go
two for you
get in the [ __ ] game awesome please
just keep going make sure you put out
content that's valuable for the people
on the other side of the video not for
you so little less selfishness and a
little more selflessness i think we'll
grow the selfishness
[Music]
three days
reliving my dreams
and i mean to be there with brandon
starting to see the early days of
the building of the intellectual
property
people falling in love with the
characters
associating
i think the kids reactions dustin are
real
they connect you know i love the digital
world i love the physical world
i love the physical digital world
and uh and i love building things
i built my family business
and my personal brand
built vayner
i'm a [ __ ] executor i'm a builder
these are gonna be the [ __ ]
documentations of rebuilding this what's
in the [ __ ] grind
dustin it's pretty straight days
that's what i do headed to [ __ ]
germany gonna meet up with be friends
in germany
i'm gonna crush my keynote
we do
that's it
[Music]